Вітаю! Мене звати Петро Коржевський.
Я заступник Міністра освіти і науки
України
Я відповідаю за розвиток
професійно-технічної освіти.
З 12 березня заклади професійно-
технічної освіти на карантині.
З цього часу уся теорія, а також усі
види практичного навчання, перенесено
на дистанційну форму.
Як змінився освітній процес у закладах
професійної освіти на період карантину?
У професійній освіті більшість навичок
опановують на практиці.
Тож теми, які неможливо адаптувати до
дистанційного навчання, МОН пропонує
перенести на період після карантину.
МОН не обмежує педагогів переліком
ресурсів для роботи.
Для організації навчання вони можуть
використовувати:
безкоштовні вебсервіси та додатки Skype,
Zoom, Google Classroom;
проводити майстер-класи або пропонувати
навчальні фільми для самостійного
перегляду;
надавати онлайн-підручники, деякі з
яких розміщені на сайті МОН;
обирати доступні матеріали із
зовнішніх освітніх ресурсів;
Корисні матеріали від педагогів і
навчально-методичних центрів зібрані
на сайті МОН у розділі
"Професійно-технічна освіта".
Для учнів проміжних курсів заклади
корегують навчальні плани та
організовують дистанційне навчання.
Для випускників, у яких на цей час
припадає державна кваліфікаційна
атестація — організовують її у
дистанційній формі.
У такий спосіб заклади вчасно видадуть
документи про освіту, не порушивши
структуру навчального року.
Якщо ж виробнича практика випускника
припала на карантин, а без неї
неможливо допустити учня
до атестації — враховуйте його оцінки
з виробничого навчання, яке він
відпрацював з майстром.
Дякую майстрам виробничого навчання,
викладачам спецдисциплін, учителям-
предметникам
та всім тим, хто доклав зусиль,
щоб працювати у нових умовах.
Нагадаю, що на період карантину за
всіма працівниками закладу зберігається
середня заробітна плата.
Вона включає доплату за класне
керівництво, кабінет чи перевірку
зошитів.
Якщо ваші права порушуються —
повідомте про це Службу освітнього
омбудсмена.
Давайте разом працювати над успішним
навчанням наших дітей.
Уся актуальна та достовірна інформація
на сайті, Фейсбуці та Телеграм-каналі
Міністерства освіти і науки.